the final moments of freedom this is
Jack tossing jahal on his wedding day in
India in October 2017 the Scottish seek
was arrested days later and has been in
detention ever since his family claim
he's been tortured
they say he's innocent of allegations of
links to the murders of Hindu nationals
and Sayed I think deep down he's broken
because he's stuck in a system that are
not charging him they're not letting him
cool and from what I see totally stalled
his wife as if I've done something then
charge me and let their trial progress
19 months on for a trial not to progress
and constant delays constant a
gentleman's Esquire meant to effect on
him he's far from the only relative
worried about jailed loved ones a Sky
News Freedom of Information request has
revealed more than 2,000 British
nationals were in detention as of
November last year on a single day that
month more than 1,000 Britons were held
despite not having a prison sentence
they were found in a hundred and seven
countries around the world the cases
included people detained without proof
of guilt like this former British
soldier Andrew Neil appeared in court in
Abu Dhabi today on drug charges he
denies his family says a prosecution
witness didn't show up so he was sent
back to his cell he's been locked up
since October Daniela has first-hand
experience of the justice system in the
United Arab Emirates her husband Matthew
hedges was also jailed there on what
they say were false charges they think
the Foreign Office should do more to
help all jailed Brits from a series of
cases that I've come face-to-face with
the most notable of my husband's case I
think it is fair to say that in a great
part the British government does
prioritize its political alliances and
its financial interests over its its own
citizens rights the foreign secretary
would probably disagree as he's
intervened personally in some cases
people have to understand that Britain's
consular services are very small in
relation to the total number of people
traveling millions and millions travel
every year and they do their very best
to look after prisoners but in a large
country with prisoners spread around
prisons different parts of the country
it can be difficult they will always be
trying to help slim comfort for these
two detainees still waiting for justice
Deborah Haines Sky News